le parlementaire béarnais jean lassalle
est à marseille le député qui marche
contre l'indifférence présente son livre
à la rencontre des français paru le mois
dernier aux éditions du cherche-midi
bonsoir jean lassalle ça alors c'est le
fruit de votre longue marche de 8 mois à
travers routes et chemins de france il
ya presque deux ans six mille kilomètres
parcourus et des milliers de rencontres
vous avez pris votre bâton de pèlerin
non pas pour répandre la bonne parole
mais pour la recueillir oui tout à fait
parce que j'avais la somme des
mannequins entre pays n'allait pas bien
il ne va pas mieux et qu'il y avait un
divorce croissant est aujourd'hui très
préoccupant entre nos concitoyens nos
compatriotes et nous mêmes vous dites
non qu'on est à la veille d'une
révolution vous y croyez
je voudrais ne pas y croire mais tout
outil par la sueur regarde objectivement
en effet les petits
petite flammèches ici ou là qui prennent
beaucoup d'importance et puis surtout
cette rupture du lien humain on constate
partout et rupture avec les politiques
et une véritable désamour que vous avez
pu constater des français pour les
politiques ah oui c'est parfois même de
la haine nos deux tests un point
inimaginable parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment que nos les représentants plus
que nous ne faisons plus remonter leurs
aspirations et que nous sommes capables
incapable de traduire un futur est à
l'horizon pour eux et pour leurs enfants
et ça c'était il ya deux ans l homme en
est on aujourd'hui est-ce que ça empire
et
malheureusement je ne crois pas et la
grande observatrice ce que vous êtes une
passe mais je pense pas la même chose
rdc élections qu'on va avoir des gens
savent plus à quoi ça sert à quoi ces
départementale quelles sont ses
compétences qu'elle l'ait fait sur les
moyens qu'est ce qu'il peut faire pour
eux je pense hélas que ça ne s'est pas
améliorée ce n'est pas l'image que nos
bons non plus qui sait qu'il a peut
l'améliorer et c'est désespérant
justement va un petit peu aidé le front
national il ya ces élections vous êtes
venu soutenir les candidats du modem
pour les départementales oui bien sûr
chez ceux venus soutenir les du môle
aime parce que ils m'ont toujours
soutenu c'est une famille et puis je
sais qu'ils sont en relation avec rudy
des candidats centristes jeudi justement
je sais pas ce que votre centriste peut
être une alternative aux autres
désespérée du front national merci
beaucoup jean lassalle et je vous
remercie d'être venu vous pouvez
retourner à votre réunion publique qui
vous attend ce soir à marseille rue
sénac et moi je remercie beaucoup